bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de check up votre
magazine santé bien-être
au sommaire de cette nouvelle édition
les dispositifs de lutte contre le virus
ebola le verrons comment les hôpitaux du
département se prépare à faire face à
l'épidémie
nous parlerons ensuite de l'allaitement
maternel en se penche sur le rôle d'une
consultante en lactation et rhinoise
au sommaire également la chirurgie mini
invasive nous sommes allés à poissy pour
découvrir ces nouvelles techniques
d'opération moins douloureuse pour les
patients mais tout d'abord place à ce
témoignage celui de lola 7 ans
diabétique depuis plusieurs années nous
l'avons rencontrée chez elle à marly le
roi à l'occasion de la journée mondiale
du diabète le 14 novembre
elle nous explique comment elle vit avec
la maladie et le diwan pour les images
parfois j'ai j'ai envie de rester et en
tant que jeu a dit si manger plein de
trous et un bonbon j'adore ça mais sinon
ça va vous retrouver pas resté longtemps
la piscine bas parce que sinon ça ici
métro et luis parce que tu as une pompe
oui voilà et quand elle se baigne on
doit débrancher la pompe pour qu'elles
puissent se baigner et donc on peut
débrancher la pompe environ une heure
une heure et demie
et ensuite la rebrancher donc voici la
pompe à insuline qui est relié par une
tubulure à un cathéter qui est sur le
haut de la fesse qui doit être changé
deux à trois fois par semaine c'est mon
chéri et donc à l'intérieur de cette
pompe vous avez un petit réservoir avec
l'insuline donc de l'insuline qui est
qui passe toute la journée en continu
comme notre propre propre ancrés à 100
fait excuser moi et au moment des repas
au moment des repas nous effectuons une
injection grâce à la pompe ce qui évite
d'utiliser une seringue ou ou un stylo à
insuline
comme d'autres ont beaucoup et ça te
dérange tout à l'heure tous sens non ça
me dérange pas elle a l'habitude
c'est vrai qu'on l'à pic sur le haut de
la fesse
elle a pris l'habitude de faire
attention à la tubulure s'est toujours
accroché à sa ceinture
parfois elle a des moments de ras-le-bol
ça la gêne est là pas en ville était
sous une robe ça la contrarie parfois un
petit peu au niveau esthétique mais
sinon on va dire qu'elle est plutôt à
l'aise avec ça comme elle dit je pense
que ce qui est difficile c'est parfois
la frustration et de ne pas se sentir
exactement comme les autres mais elle
peut faire tout autant que les autres
elle peut manger comme les autres tout
est une question d'équilibré finalement
un enfant diabétique peut manger comme
n'importe quel autre enfant et tous les
gens tout le monde devrait manger en
fait comme quelqu'un de diabétiques
c'est-à-dire équilibré manger deux tours
et la pompe c'est un gros confort donc
nous avons un appareil à dextro avec un
autopiqueur lola doit faire une indexed
row avant chaque repas pour mesurer le
taux de sucre dans son sens hop voilà
paz y est donc elle récupère la petite
goutte de sang qui va nous donner le
taux de sucre qu'elle a dans le sang à
ce moment là on peut savoir si elle est
en hypoglycémie donc si elle a trop peu
de sucre dans le sang ce qui nécessitera
qu'elles soient reçues créés ou si elle
a vraiment trop de sucre dans le sang
en dehors des repas pour permettre de
faire une autre injection d'insuline
pour que son taux redevienne à la
normale faut réussir à le vivre et si on
n'y arrive pas faut quand même le faire
plus de 5000 décès c'est le dernier
bilan de l'épidémie ebola à ce jour
malgré des progrès remarqués ces
derniers temps les experts et les
autorités restent fermes
il faut rester très vigilant face à ce
virus dans les yvelines les
établissements se prépare à recevoir des
cas éventuels comme au centre
hospitalier de poissy saint germain en
laye où nous sommes rendus et le diwan
pour les images à l'accueil du service
des urgences de l'hôpital
poissy-saint-germain-en-laye le patient
ne peut pas y échapper
ces affiches placardées sur les murs
alerte sur le virus ebola mettre un
masque se laver les mains ce sont les
premières précautions à suivre si un
patient présente de la fièvre et revient
des pays atteints par l'épidémie
l'infirmière à l'accueil lui demande
alors de sortir et de suivre ce circuit
spécifique à l'extérieur donc le patient
est accueillie ici est isolé dans la
salle d'examen immédiatement ce qui
limite les contacts dans le service avec
les patients et les personnels de santé
et vous avez ici pour le personnel la
procédure d'habillage et de déshabillage
pour permettre d'avoir des mesures de
protection individuelle les plus
efficaces possibles
c'est en effet dans cette zone qui en
binôme formé d'un médecin et d'une
infirmière confirmé sa vie selon ses
règles très rigoureuse grâce à des kits
de protection individuelle spécial ebola
ranger dans cette salle un peu plus loin
tout est fait pour éviter les risques de
contact et de contamination dès que les
professionnels de santé sont paraît il
procède à un interrogatoire du cas
suspect dans une salle d'examen standard
entièrement vidées pour l'occasion
aucun prélèvement nier
lisez et le patient n'en sort pas
jusqu'à ce qu'une décision soit prise
soit le cas suspects élevé dans la
plupart des cas c'est ce qui arrive
c'est à dire qu'en fait on pensait que
c'était possible et finalement on lit
avec le salut ligue nvs l ars ce cas
n'est pas confirmé ou si ce cas devient
possible à ce moment là il est
transporté par le samu qui va le
chercher ici dans le centre de référence
l'hôpital bichat pour les adultes et
l'hôpital necker pour les enfants tous
deux situés à paris sous les centres de
référence c'est là que les prélèvements
sont réalisés sur les patients les
prélèvements sont envoyés à lyon et dans
les 6 à 12 heures le diagnostic est
confirmé ou non pour l'instant aucun cas
suspect n'a dû être isolé selon cette
procédure dans l'établissement du 12 au
19 octobre c'était la semaine mondiale
de l'allaitement maternel
l'occasion pour les professionnels de
santé d'échanger d'informer et de
soutenir cette pratique nous avons
rencontré une conseillère en lactation
yvelinoise elle nous raconte quel est
son rôle auprès des mamans
patrick jacq gaullisme et pour les
images c'est la deuxième fois que sophie
reçoit margaret chez elle depuis la
naissance de son troisième enfant cette
jeune maman rencontrent des difficultés
à l'allaitement
en fait la luna dès la naissance j'avais
eu des douleurs à l'hôpital il m'avait
dit que ça passerait en quand elle
grandira et que ça bouge allait grandir
aussi donc tous allés se mettre en place
et puis les jours ont passé les douleurs
ont persisté sur les conseils d'une amie
elle fait donc appel à margaret
consultante en lactation à domicile son
verdict tombe rapidement la petite luna
un frein de langue trop court qui
l'empêchent d'allaiter convenablement le
bébé a donc subi une petite opération et
fait quelques séances de rééducation et
s'ils ont une échelle de douleurs 0 à 10
là par exemple celle là 3 vous êtes à
thouars d'accord parce que les problèmes
pour lesquels les mamans font appel à
margaret sont variés mais ce qui revient
souvent c'est le fait que les
professionnels de santé donne de
mauvaises informations aux mamans c'est
pas il manque de bonne volonté s'il
n'est pas une manque de bienveillance
c'est juste que beaucoup de
professionnels de santé n'ont pas reçu
une formation
sur l'allaitement maternel à la
différence des sages femmes qui ont
plusieurs tâches
la consultante en lactation elle est
uniquement spécialisé en allaitement
il arrive parfois qu'il accompagne les
sages femmes ou les puéricultrices
car ses connaissances dans le domaine ne
sont plus poussés surtout je suis là
pour écouter la maman pour comprendre
ces difficultés et pour essayer
d'apporter avec une information une aide
des solutions je lui propose des
solutions
après c'est à la maman de voir un
capital souhaite suivre dans les
yvelines comme margaret environ 5
consultante en lactation exerce au
domicile des mamans lundi 20 octobre
c'était la journée mondiale de la
douleur
à cette occasion nous sommes allés à la
rencontre des chirurgiens yvelinois qui
pratique des techniques d'intervention
moins agressive pour les patients c'est
la chirurgie mini invasive
elle permet aussi de réduire les temps
d'hospitalisation reportage à la
clinique saint louis de poissy des
images de william l
le chirurgien se prépare lors de cette
intervention il va éliminer les calculs
rénaux d'un jeune homme ces petits
cristaux contenues dans les urines qui
peuvent grossir et provoquer des
douleurs très intense pour un homme
c'est un une des douleurs les plus
importants qui peut vivre puisque on
compare ce la douleur de la colique
néphrétique donc la maladie que posent
les calculs à la douleur d'un
accouchement sans anesthésie pour
extraire les calculs il va utiliser ce
qu'on appelle la chirurgie mini invasive
grâce à une petite caméra et de la
lumière qu'on peut insérer dans le corps
à l'aide de tuyaux très fin le
chirurgien peut aller chercher et
retirer les calculs en passant par la
verge
voilà donc là on est dans le canal de
l'urètre ont fait en passant petit
coudes et on se retrouve dans la vessie
lorsque les calculs sont trop gros le
chirurgien peut même les pulvériser
directement dans le corps grâce à cette
fibre laser d'une taille minuscule de 2
160 microns quelques minutes plus tard
l'intervention est terminée les calculs
du jeune homme sont tous éliminés
il va pouvoir sortir d'ici deux trois
heures dans les conditions de la
chirurgie ambulatoire moi il ya vingt
ans quand j'apprenais la chirurgie avec
le maître des chirurgies je les voyais
faire prendre un bistouri et faire une
incision de 10 cm pour des calculs que
je traite maintenant sans en avoir du
tout affaire d'incision donc ces mini
invasive dans la mesure où on rentre
jusqu'au bout de l'intérieur du corps de
quelqu'un mais sans aucun dommage
corporel s'il faut dire parce que
l'incision ça reste un dommage qu'on a
le droit de poser aux passions la
chirurgie mini invasive dont le matériel
coûte cher et nécessite de lourds
investissements est l'un des axes
majeurs de la clinique saint louis à
poissy quelques mètres plus loin cette
chirurgie est aussi pratiqué ici sur le
pied l'hallux valgus appelé plus
familièrement l'oignon du pied est une
déformation du gros orteil avant pour le
père et le pied et est ouvert de l'eau
en large et tous les plans au souhaitait
exposer une opération réputé extrêmement
douloureuse aujourd'hui grâce à ces
nouvelles techniques
on souffre mois pour deux raisons
principales on fait des petites
ouvertures et percutanée comme vous avez
vus à travers des petits trous donc les
gens souffrent très peu puisque on ouvre
très peu le pied et en délabre très peu
les parties molles qui entourent l'os et
on n'est pas obligé d'exposer tout l'os
pour pouvoir effectuer cette
intervention
c'est également grâce à un protocole
d'alice tizi moderne où on va
sélectionner le nerf qui s'occupe de la
sensibilité du quai de façon il active
donc l'anesthésiste va le repérer par
une échographie ou par la
neurostimulation et de comme vous voyez
ici à l'arrière du genou
il vient poser un cathéter à l'aide de
ce cathéter les médecins diffuse un
produit permettant aux patients de ne
plus sentir leurs pieds les premières 48
heures censés être les plus difficiles à
la clinique san louis la chirurgie mini
invasive se développe depuis l'année
dernière et en france d'après les
médecins elle fait son arrivée depuis
une dizaine d'années mais compte pour
l'instant peu de pratiquants
cette chirurgie nécessite en effet une
formation spécifique et ne s'apprend pas
du jour au lendemain
ce numéro de check up touche à sa fin
avant de nous quitter vous le savez
place au traditionnel agenda le mercredi
26 novembre une collecte de sang est
organisée à montigny le bretonneux
le véhicule sera stationné à proximité
du centre commercial rendez-vous de
12h30 à 18h le vendredi 5 décembre la
ville de plaisir s'engage pour le
téléthon et organise une zimbawe géante
prévoyez vos tenues les plus colorés car
l'événement est placé sous le signe du
fluo un événement ouvert à tous dès 19h
sur le parvis du château check up s'est
terminé merci de votre attention je vous
donne rendez-vous dans un mois
d'ici là portez vous bien